this is a satellite photo of an
uncharted island in the South Pacific
a place where myth and science meet Kong
has been rican sieved as a myth come to
life
this film will be an immersive spectacle
he got Kong that's a hundred feet tall
it really has to be seen in IMAX the
whole movie just gets taken to the next
level Washington IMAX you really just
lose yourself what the hell is this
place
it tells this incredible story of man
versus nature you came here looking for
a track at who old what am i tracking
I've been looking for this island for
years get us home
with proof monsters exist the island
isn't just a place that looks
specifically like one thing as you
continue to travel through it you see
the variations it's never been touched
you don't know what to expect like any
natural jungle there are predators
you don't go into someone's house and
start dropping bombs unless you're
picking a fight
Kong is killing his men so it becomes
his mission it's time to show that man
is king he's not an animal he's not a
beast he's a being and it's just
something that we don't understand yet
he is truly monstrous in size and scale
and scope when people step foot on this
island
the first visceral response is to look
at that thing and say that's a god
that's the big one
I hope the film inspires Wanda and/or
Kong Skull Island takes you to a
different world where things are
beautiful and terrifying all at the same
time it's IMAX and it's 3d it's huge and
we're talking about one of the greatest
myths of all time
it's a good group of voice we're all
gonna die together out here come
experience it in IMAX 3d
you